All musical compositions or performances have a beginning and an end.
But unlike other art forms, the art of music does not conclude with the end of the performance...
...or the listening of a soundtrack.
This is because music has the attribute of both affecting each individual differently,...
...and living on inside the individual like an emotional stamp planted in the mind.
This can occur in one of two ways:...
...either the person will consciously create whatever image or story they feel like as they listen to the music,...
...most probably based on their aspirations or current personal situations.
Or the association may occur at a subconscious level...
...as the individual is performing some task...
...or is immersed in a personal crisis...
...or intense situation when the music is playing in the background.
A musical performance itself might develop into a strong memory as well.
For example, before a concert gets under way,...
...a person might have the chance to meet one of the performers.
Or there might simply be a feeling of nostalgia when the concert is finishing up...
...and the person realizes the great time that he just had with loved ones or good friends at the concert.
Regardless of what kind or how the bond is established between the music and an emotional feeling or memory,...
...it may end up being a strong one that will last a lifetime.
In this aspect, music is unlike any other form of art.